hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to leave now we just
survived a crash that we probably
shouldn't survive this guy didn't
survive it over here and we're in the
abandoned mines where everyone died a
horrible death from death poisoning from
all these mushrooms so we're gonna find
out exactly where and why and how
everybody died very soon um and also I
want to point out that in the last
episode I very much hello hi
I very much made the counter-argument to
what I was trying to do is trying to go
like oh I'm not gonna compare this too
much damn neva and then I subsequently
only compared it to amnesia what the
hell is this why is there a window way
down here this is like a bum ground
architecture why would this be all the
way down here man it's got to be weird
building this place well Hank I got
crank up the volume
oh well that ain't good hi oh [ __ ] that
sounds the opposite of good
okay so there's apparently something
else down here with me
is that what I'm saying talking hell hi
okay nevermind then don't step on those
mushrooms and don't get in the way of
those things because they're gonna kill
me and apparently there's a lot of
things that are gonna kill me down here
but I'm
hi sure okay okay I'm trying to come up
with clever and witty things to say I
think I'm supposed to go through here
yes ah good towards the fires of hell
why not because I can cozy's oh this is
all so good it's so cool like I gotta
admit it's so well done okay so I'm
assuming that I gotta find where these
pipes go that I could have turned off
the valves the high-pressure gas is
flowing out so I don't give her to the
person
I follow these kind fare but if I follow
them generally I should be able to get
to a place where
oh man was so dark it's so dark I don't
have a flashlight or nothing Oh
oh man just stumbling around in the
darkness that's what I love though I
mean I hate it right now but I love it
just because it's that element of
unknown going into a game that I've
never experienced before it's just so
cool I don't know what its gonna throw
at me I don't know if it's gonna be good
or bad it's probably gonna be horrible
hey oh hey hi you're the first other
human I've seen besides skeletons if you
want to count them and I don't know if
you're gonna count that you're gonna be
a skeleton soon hello don't mind as I
t-bag your body ah yeah you've looked
better
okay I'll carry on my way okay so these
things ah okay that was a good noise all
right great
ah I'm supposed to get them in the sweet
spot okay ah haha I did it somehow I
know exactly how to use all these
wonderful machinations deep down the
darkness at least know how to get out of
the way so what do I do it looks like oh
I knew I don't it's about saying this
looked like a hidey hole coming it let's
go again
coming up bra coming up right
coming up Wow I saw the tip down below
hey all right now 92 I want to see it
but I don't know
hi bye are you going probably did I make
sure oh god damn it my sensitivity on my
microphone was laid too high sorry if
that blasted out everyone's eardrums oh
boy oh boy you're stably stumbly oh boy
oh my friend hi friend oh you sound good
good no why why did you kick that barrel
what did that ever do to you what are
you doing expressing your rage in the
form of aggression oh come on man gotta
be kinder you gotta be kinder
I think I'm good I want to get a good
look at this thing I mean there's a
ladder right here I don't think you can
follow me up so we go take a good look
hello hi friend
hello my friend friend friend friend
crap
where did friend go friend gone
friendo mo o friend no mo doesn't sound
like friend no more but apparently
friend no mo okay bye
gonna be on my way then cuz he doesn't
want to play right now I want to play
later but that's besides here are the
noises oh good what the hell is the list
then ha I went down many many many many
stories I can't believe that the earth
is right there to the fortunate reader
here's some food to help you out or
should I say unfortunate for still being
here I'm not sure if anybody will
actually read this but I'm sure it could
be of some use to somebody I don't want
it anymore I don't need it I evolved far
beyond the capacity for that
excuse my spin oh jeez
all righty then well this all looks well
built and good and who built this a boat
oh here adobe of abode goodbye sorry I'm
turning into the monster already why do
I wish to jump in there Jim
wow that's deep what would happen if I
fell on down is there a safe mechanic no
and I'll save that for later I'm sure
I'm gonna do it accidentally at some
point drop pouring up what I'm not that
stupid that I would dive headfirst into
a pit of death over there we're [ __ ]
pocket for
a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass piece of [ __ ] god
damn it
oh okay I'm back now we're back and not
being so stupid as last time okay so
anyway we're going through here red my
favorite color not really hello
why can't I go in here why is everything
of Perpetual sewers you know just going
through this oh thank you you know going
through this place I'm kind of confused
as to the layout it seems to be a weird
combination of sewers / industrial shaft
/ living situation and I don't know
exactly what they were mining out but
I'm going into the restricted area it
seems I've been on the right track my
new refinement techniques have provided
me an incredible effective type of
restroom restorative and after through
experimentation I have started using the
tincture more commonly and appears to
have many if not infinite applications
it has even enabled me to get rid of
this horrible migraine I've been having
recently
I'm dr. Rosenberg yeah and it probably
turns you into horrible monstrosity to
wander around and cause me problems
what can I not go through here is this
restricted okay then I suppose not down
there just yet and is it called lot down
animam is it loud down in them can I go
here
can I jump no I get up there okay
it almost come on little more don't be
like that
there we go nope come on little more oh
you're not gonna let me through
it looks like it's obviously where I'm
supposed to go but apparently my head is
just two gigantic to fit over this gap
goodbye
oh oh I was supposed to go through there
I just wasn't going out at the right
angle okay that makes no sense
hello it's a save point hey this is food
stuff in my face
Dave 349 the communications are still
out and we have yet to figure out a way
out of here what will happen to us where
the hell are we well I mean right
outside was a pit to the above if you
could have gotten some rope it wouldn't
have been too difficult to get out of
here I mean it was a bright sunshiny day
outside unless I was just shot
Mike Reba I should walk what is this
this is an elevator that looks dark and
industrial oh the orchestra's picking up
yeah I hope no one comes yet you find me
they're not your anything too crazy like
jump ah ow
my ankles oh no I was supposed to do
that huh that hurt way that was close to
death they really want to kill me in
this endeavor I really don't know if I
was supposed to do that oh I was
supposed to jump on the pipe first ah
well it's good thing I got these health
tonics because they can protect me from
my own stupidity of which I have a great
deal
nice elevator access what about this
right here it looks elevator e oh you
oddly enough
besides amnesia I'm getting a lot of
memories from penumbra because penumbra
was actually kind of an industrial thing
like this as well whereas amnesia was
old like old castle and whatnot but this
is what is very industrial it's like
okay was I supposed to come here I'm so
sneaky and Shelby no one can stop me
from my objective is ooh
anyone want my creeper hands in their
business oh okay let's keep to myself
seems like I'm just wandering in circles
to be honest vast of more food in my
face surface access well it's obviously
I'm not gonna be able to get to the
surface it's not gonna let me there's
only episode 1 of a multi-episode game
it's just the beginning of a new wall no
oh boy we've reached back to the body
bags Dave for 347 leaving the coastal
mine wasn't exactly an easy task the
road leading to the administration
office that runs through the village is
covered with a thick black corrosive
liquid for a distance of 200 meters or
more there's no way we could have come
through that route alive and walking all
the way around the cliffs would take a
day at the very least if not more we
decided to meet the other groups at the
office but all we all we found were
there were locked doors and broken
machinery we're trapped who knows how
deep beneath the 3rd 5th ok oh [ __ ] come
on oh you can't close it off like that
I just got somewhere ah titty sprinkles
okay am I supposed to go back that way
possibly I'm getting so turned around I
have no idea where I am or where I
wasn't wait a minute wait that door
wasn't the store wasn't open before
something bashing
yay good yes hope I don't have to hide
out in here oh no oh why why why would I
have to do that ah why
oh I'm oh this is afraid for me oh good
I needed that so I wouldn't piss my
pants in front of all the monsters I'm
glad they added that mechanic in the
game uh glad I took a break glad I took
that break okay all right carrying on
don't know why I did that I guess I
could go down here again okay what about
over here I think if I keep above I
think my problem was I dropped down over
here and this was just leading to
another another note but if I go back up
and I go all the way around and I follow
the route I should be able to get to
where I need to go just a little whoa no
oh okay that's good all right I thought
I was gonna ruin everything and I wasn't
gonna be able to progress because
everything is physics baby yeah no one
can stop me no ding-dang-dong physics
goodbye excuse me pardon me sorry excuse
my girth
oh there's a lot of squeaky strong keys
going off out there I don't exactly know
what it all means but wait a minute oh
this is cycled back oh there was no
point to that there was no point to any
of that ah that was useless okay so I
guess I'd go back up there's nothing
else to do here whoops okay all right
goodbye now that I took my piss prick
carry on with the rest of his game
pamela not able to I can't go through
okay
if you wanted to confuse me you're doing
a great job
oh stop it wait a minute what the [ __ ]
is this oh it's different
oh it's different I thought it was the
same as different whoo hello you stay
over there you be good I'll come get you
later
I'm assuming this doors locked yeah okay
into the crawlspace we go yeah look good
someone put some food in here not that I
need any more of it I'm pretty held up
all right what else you got for me well
that's a bad sound he's really quiet
oh it's crying oh it's quite oh it's so
quiet
now that we've gotten my oh I didn't
need to know that well [ __ ] that ruined
the quiet day 3:51 Niko's is gone poor
guy didn't stand a chance against the
worker in the suit who is he why is he
trying to kill us
if we can make it to the labs then we
might have a chance I've ever seen the
light of day again I saw the light of
day it's pretty nice I didn't go into it
and try to get to it I'm wandering
around down here
and sticking cycles oh nice
ah thank you okay so now I got a route
back and hopefully this good chunk yeah
I had good luck the last time I went
into an elevator I'm sure that's gonna
go lovely excuse me for needing to drink
a water all right what else you got in
the store from me oh I can't move some
elevator ride clued me into place all
right I'm waiting I'm ready
I'm hoping that if it starts to throw
more soon because now it's gotten me
into the introduction of the world and I
feel like it needs to pump up the horror
aspect of it very soon like the solitude
is nice but it definitely needs some
crisis ok I can't go in the archives
what if I wanted to learn I guess also
the problem is a lot of this looks the
same and it's hard to differentiate
anything when everything is pitch black
like this which is both good and bad
especially in a horror game like
darkness is the most common theme in
horror games just because darkness is
the most primal primal reaction of fear
that a human cannot like experience like
when it's dark the unknown is there and
it taps into like the idea that anything
could be there so my brain is gonna make
up all the threats that could possibly
try and kill me but fortunately it also
means I can't see [ __ ] head pit uh ok I
guess we're finally going to get to the
bottom of the noise here even though I
just been venturing down and down and
down and down caution advised warning
protective equipment required in this
area keep hands clear of machinery I
don't think I will I'm gonna mess with
everything I see and try to break it all
oh do I gotta go in there I bet I do
I thought I do yep I gotta go in there
ok Oh No
okay that's cool I mean that's not cool
but it's kind of cool that's a good way
to do things yeah yeah oh oh nothing
again nothing those like the best set up
you're gonna have what the [ __ ] was that
look it even at a sign with an
exclamation mark on it oh I was like a
setup oh man yeah okay all right maybe I
would have been too easy do cliched okay
ooh hi what happened to you guys are you
gonna tell me hey sir excuse me don't
make me keep like grabby hands okay all
right did something kill you is it
something that I should look out for
there's a lot of bodies down there and
they're all so meticulously wrapped this
one captive lacklustre lee laid out but
you know it makes me wonder who did this
like who took the time to carefully wrap
all the bodies that's definitely a thing
that took some effort what is that
it's a hanging body I bet I'm gonna go
down there soon oh it's a Skellington
right next to a body okay lots of bodies
oh all right okay all right okay hey
what was that hi
okay so that's only the third time that
I've seen a monster but I'm waiting for
something to happen oh when are you
gonna do something you gonna stop oh
good music
who dat music I gotta appreciate good
news hello another checkpoint alright
carrying on laughs um is that close to
laDawn and um Nana
they keep giving me food but I really
don't need it I'm not I'm not being
attacked by everything can I get up
how about can I get down through it
moved me more food don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
with the goddamn bear trap I thought we
were over this they're just using the
bear traps as a jump-scare mechanic when
they could use actually something with
some substance like monsters looking of
the darkness okay ah good very
convenient that all that was laid out to
protect me from this a blue ink okay so
oh that's a health doodad
because once again I can't see [ __ ] run
I'm gonna stand my ground
oh oh hi are you doing hi [ __ ] ah
okay asking you shall receive me
okay going the right way probably not
can't see [ __ ] can't see [ __ ] in our boy
oh gonna run out of stamina boy what
happens if I what's that I drink it well
that was good
good thing I got a swig of booze right
as I was running away from this monster
okay so it's not faster than me that's
for sure I don't know if it lost me my
rights
hmm I'll keep seeing shadows in the
darkness and hearing noises I don't know
what identifies the monster noise yet oh
man hello hello it me Punk thunk I'm
gonna run smack into it
come on hello oh that's bad
that sounds bad which way did I go Oh
what's this woo hello did I find secret
oh this probably leads me this probably
leads into the other area who put up
body back down here who put it here who
put it here he didn't die wrapped up
unless he did then he was just an idiot
oh where did this lead Rick this isn't
where I was thinking oh it's so dark
can't see I can't see [ __ ]
oh hello is this like a thing
geez I can't see in stock whoa okay crew
like a ninja ah [ __ ] [ __ ] well [ __ ]
oh oh god oh oh god I didn't know that I
can actually go underwater oh okay
alrighty then ah man it sure is taking
me places like I will admit about this
game like i may have complained a bit
that it was getting like repetitive but
man this game travels feels like amnesia
you were going back and forth between
areas a lot to try to solve puzzles but
this one just is like move forward is
hard and fast as you can dave 352 i
don't feel so well today I'm sweating
too my legs are shaking maybe we should
spend the night here and get some rest
I'm sure the boy could use it he barely
talks and how could he his father was
murdered in front of his eyes just a few
hours ago we even barely made it out
alive it was if it wasn't for Nico's
well that's not good okay
alright why why is there a boy down here
oh lordy
you know like you this you know like he
this you know lucky ok hello hello I'm
my red door that is obviously locked
hello ominous dark hallway with a light
at the end of it
flickering so ominously hello ominous
side hall with ominous light casting oh
my god I don't have a shadow I'm a ghost
oh [ __ ] dude oh [ __ ] dude I know
something's gonna happen okay oh good oh
good every day 355 this horrible rash on
my skin is driving me crazy and I think
I might be showing signs of poisoning
you can barely move my legs yet
sometimes I feel this violent rush that
makes my blood boil I'm not sure if the
boy is safe with me
he should continue on his own I don't
think I'm going to make it anyway I hope
the kid didn't notice but I started
coughing up blood today he's been
through enough already so I don't really
want to worry him if he can reach the
labs he might even be able to get me
some help as topi makes it for his sake
and mine well judging by the deadness of
the you I'm assuming that you didn't
make it alrighty then
oh well my friendly notes are gonna all
stop geez munch munch I don't need him
who's buying this door
well I know good voters no good at all
what happening there are you alright are
you just taking a wicked piss I did that
earlier it was it was something all
right
oh no this is the place oh no this is
the bathroom maybe I should stop and
take a poopy here maybe maybe not
okay go bye uh at least I got all the
notes apparently that's good for me
okay hello ominous red light at the end
of this ominous hallway or did I come
from over here
ah I can't Oh exit oh I believe that
with all my heart
oh my is this a thing oh is the thing I
gotta crawl down of course
this won't work of course you're home oh
that won't work either
I gotta crawl in the hole in the wall
there you good yes
at least this one has some ambiance all
good is that gonna chop me up into
little pieces
what is this where does this lead that
ain't good I doubt that's gonna be
enough to actually suck me up and chop
me up in it but you never know with
these things yo I may I may have
criticized in this episode the pacing
but actually I take that back I realized
oh [ __ ] I've been scared by goddamn bear
traps more than anything more than
goddamn anything oh man all right but
actually I take it back like I think it
actually is quite good I'm thoroughly
enjoying this in this adventure so
either way I'm gonna end this episode
here I'm gonna pick this up don't worry
there's gonna be new videos of this
pretty much every day until the game is
done and then more episodes in the
actual game at some point in the future
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
oh just go oh my god
now for you would you like me to